now let's do a slightly fancier example
then we'll try to analyze the vector
field and hopefully this will
make everything a little bit more
tangible so let's say that the velocity
of the fluid or the particles in the
fluid at any given point
in the x y plane let's say
the in the x direction it is x squared
x squared
minus three x
plus 2
in the x direction
plus
y squared minus
3y
plus 2 in the y direction make it make
it simple so that
we only have one thing to factor so
let's just do the math first let's
figure out the divergence
of our vector field
the divergence
of our field and i'm going to show you a
graph of this field soon so we'll get an
intuition of what it actually looks like
instead of my
my not so accurate drawings
so what's the divergence we take the
partial derivative of the x component
with respect to x
so that's just there's only an x
variable here so we don't have to worry
about keeping y or z constant so it's
really just the derivative of this
expression with respect to x
so it's 2x
minus 3
and then we add that to the partial
derivative of the y component or the y
function with respect to y there's only
y's in the y component so we just take
the derivative with respect to y so it's
plus
two y
minus
three
or we could just say that the divergence
of v at any point x y so this is a
function of x and y
is two x plus two y
minus three
now before we before i show you the
graph let's let's
analyze this function a little bit first
of all let's just look at look at the
original vector field and think about
when is that vector field equal to z
whoops
when does that vector field have some
interesting points
well i think some interesting points are
when either the x or the y components
are equal to zero so when is the x
component equal to zero
well if we factor the x component that's
the same thing as
we could rewrite our vector field
if we just factored that that's
x minus
1 times
x minus 2
i
plus and it's the same polynomial just
with y
for the y component so y
minus 1 times y
minus 2 times j
so the x component is 0 when x is equal
to 1 these are just the roots of this
polynomial when x is equal to 1 or 2
right and the y component is 0 when y is
equal to one or two and they're both
equal to zero if we have any combination
of these points so the points where
they're both equal to zero are
one
one
x's is one y is two right because then
both components are zero
two
one
or two two
so these are the points where the
magnitude of the velocity
of our fluid or the particles of the
fluid are zero and we'll see that in our
graph in a second
and let me ask you another question at
what points are well let's first of all
at what point is are the divergence is
the divergence equal to zero let's say
at what point is the divergence equal to
zero let me clear up some space
i think i can delete this we got our
points
we figured out what coordinates
are the magnitude of the vector field
zero
so let's try to figure out when does the
divergence
when is the divergence equal to zero
so this is divergence so if we say if we
set that equal to zero two x
plus two y
two x plus two y oh sorry you know what
this is 2x minus 3 plus 2y minus 3 so
this is minus 6 right minus 3 minus 3
that's minus 6.
that's my that's my major flaw adding
and subtracting anyway so the divergence
2x plus 2y
minus 6.
and we want to know when does that equal
zero so let's set it equal to zero
and we could simplify this a little bit
we could divide both sides of the
equation by two and you get x plus y
minus three is equal to zero
you get
x plus y is equal to three we could be
finished there or we could just put it
in our traditional
point uh mx plus b form that's that's
the way i i find it easier to visualize
a line we could say y is equal to three
minus x
so along this line the divergence
of the vector field v
is equal to zero along the line y is
equal to three minus x and if we're
above that line the divergence is going
to be positive right because if you just
made this a greater than sign that would
carry over and you'd have y is greater
than 3 minus x so
y greater than 3 minus x the divergence
is positive
and y is less than 3 minus x the
divergence is negative and you could
just make this a less than sign and then
solve and you'll get y is less than 3
minus x if you want to know when the
divergence is negative so i think we've
done all of the analyzing we can do so
let's take a look at the graph and see
if it if it's consistent with our
intuition of what a divergence is in the
numbers we found
i hope you can see this
so this is the vector field
i don't have space to
show it
but i think you remember this is you
know x squared minus three x plus two
and this this is the definition of our
vector field have it graphed here and we
figured out we just figured out when the
x components and the y components are
equal to zero and then we said when are
both of them equal to zero and we said
oh you know at the point one one well
this is the point one one and we see
that the magnitudes of the vectors are
zero at that point and actually i could
zoom in a little bit
right around here they're all pointing
inwards but they get smaller and smaller
as we point as we approach the point one
one right we also said at the point one
two x is one y is two and here two we
see that the magnitude of the vectors
get very very very small
we could zoom in again
and we see the magnitude gets very small
the other points two one once again we
see the magnitude gets small and then
two two so that's consistent with what
we found out that the vector field gets
very small at that point
and the other interesting thing we said
okay when does the divergence equal zero
well the diver that
the divergence equals zero along the
line y is equal to three minus x
so the y the line y is equal to three
minus x starts the y intercept's going
to be three it's going to come down like
this
right so anything along at any point
along that line the divergence is zero
and if we look at if we actually look at
the graph it it makes sense because
i can't draw on this graph but if we
drew a circle right there if we do a
circle right there let's assume that
that's on that the the line y is equal
to 3 minus x we would see that just as
in a given amount of time just as much
many particles are entering to the top
right as leaving through the bottom left
right a ladder entering through the top
right and a ladder leaving through the
bottom left and the vectors though are
about the same and if if we go to the
bottom if we go here on the line maybe
there are
it looks like you know maybe there are
less entering but there's also less
leaving i know it's hard to see but
anywhere along the line you see just as
much as entering is leaving and that's
why the divergence is zero
now
let's look at some of the other points
so up here we figured out the divergence
is positive and does that make sense
let's pick an arbitrary point if we if
we were to draw a circle around here
we see the vectors on the left hand side
of that circle that you can't see
because i can't draw on this graph
but we actually let's just say the
square let's say the square is my my
region right this one right here
if that square is my region we see the
vectors on the left hand side are larger
the vectors leaving are larger than the
vectors entering it right
so if in a given amount of time the more
is leaving than entering then i have
that i'm becoming less dense or you
could say that the particles are
diverging and that makes sense because i
have a positive divergence and if we go
here where the divergence is negative
let's pick a an arbitrary spot let's say
this
square right here we see that the vector
is entering it
the vectors x the magnitude of the
vectors entering it are larger than the
magnitude of the vectors exiting it so
in any given amount of time more is
coming in than leaving so it's getting
denser or it's cut converging so
negative divergence you can view it as
getting denser or it's actually
converging
actually something is interest something
interesting is happening at at these two
points
in the
so we said that x is x is uh at the
point 2 1
we see that in the y direction it's
actually converging right if we
these above
above y is equal to 1 the arrows are
pointing down and below it the arrows
are pointing up
right so in the y direction we're
actually converging or we have a
negative divergence things are entering
any given spot
but in the x direction things are
getting pushed out
right so the reason why the divergence
is zero here though you might have
particles entering above and below
a certain space but you have just as
many particles exiting through the left
and the right so it's kind of like
particles are getting deflected out so
you on a net basis between in both
dimensions you have no increase or
decrease in density along the that line
y is equal to 3 minus x and before i run
a time i just want to give you that core
intuition again of why the divergence
is positive and why that means that
things are flowing out when the the rate
of change is positive so we said the
diversion is positive let's say this
spot right
so it makes sense if our partial
derivatives are positive that means that
the magnitude of our vector is getting
larger and larger for larger values of
our x's and y's right so if the
magnitude of our vectors are getting
larger and larger for values of larger
values of x and y's the vectors on the
right are going to have a larger
magnitude than the vectors on the left
they're increasing in magnitude and so
if i were to draw
a boundary
more is going to be coming out of the
right than entering to the left and so
you have a positive divergence or you're
getting less dense anyway i hope i
haven't confused you too much
but i have run out of time once again
i'll see you in the next video